hi hi we're taking might fall
skin perspiration comes through in
different places on the body and you
never know when it's gonna happen okay I
stopped there maybe you said your you
perspire you sweat a lot no it it
wouldn't know I it isn't perspiration
per se but it smells like a dead armpit
and it will come through anywhere in the
body okay I'm trying several times a day
sometime not for a week or two or you
know do you have any skin issues any
eczema dermatitis psoriasis rosacea dry
itchy skin rough skin no okay
any respiratory problems asthma
bronchitis
Seocho yeah is that a yes that's me
that's me yes okay how much you weigh
and hold you almost 90 and weight 160
160 pounds here almost 90 years old yes
okay dear very very good okay now
Charmaine what's going on here she has
asthma okay and she was very emphatic
about that and of course she has his
hidden odor the kind of floats around
the concerns her she weighs 160 pounds
she's 90 years old
and what we do for her well she's got to
get on a gluten-free diet no wheat
barley rye oats because that's the
initial problem yeah absorption is a
problem of course everybody in your
household including the dog the cat the
bird the fish spouse renter caregiver
kids brothers and sisters renters
roommates everybody's got to be dropped
dead gluten free so you don't get
cross-contaminated and a char said you
get rid of all the bad foods the fried
foods the process meats oils and in
glutens and then what would you give her
as a program Charmaine to support a
healthy life well I think I would just
give her to Healthy Start PacSun give
her some vitamin d3 okay
all right very good otherwise healthy
okay let's the saver
the money and go with two healthy start
packs two healthy start packs so one
full dose starting of breakfast and
dinner time and then let's see here a
vitamin D I throw in some vitamins III
90 years old I'd throw in some vitamin
d3 two bottles of that so you take three
of those twice a day and see here just
make sure that you're staying away from
that grain everybody's got to stay away
from the grain you can have baked sweet
potatoes with butter and cinnamon you
can have vegetables all you want just
make sure you're in that zone as opposed
to eating oatmeal for breakfast every
morning and having toast for breakfast
every morning as I do not do that and
then give us a call every couple weeks
Andra will walk you through this because
ninety I mean people in these long-lived
cultures they lived be 120 130 150 160
200 and so you may just be halfway there
if you do everything correct so we we
would love for you to be the first one
so we'll look forward to hearing from
you every two weeks here